[musique]
dans les alentours
il n'y a pas de porte
J'ai dit porte
[musique]
Pourquoi ne peux-tu pas
Ouvre la porte arrière dans un endroit solitaire
par derrière
J'aime les catastrophes
Tu es
obstacle
qu'est-ce que c'est
[musique]
J'ai des ennuis même si je te suis
vous avez dit
C'est une chaise
[musique]
je cherche un chat
Kyūshūdepuis
à partir de maintenant
beaucoup de gens meurent
accrochez-vous
M. Sparrow, vous verrouillez la porte
S'il vous plaît, je ne peux plus le faire
stupidité
N'as-tu pas peur d'être en colère
Je crains
seulement quand on le touche
je vais surement aller t'aider
Il se traite avec négligence
j'ai l'impression que je vais le rendre
Passe une bonne journée
merci
[musique]
Je vais